we should also mention that
and during the prayer as you've
explained you
should face Mecca
so what is Mecca and
what's the experience of visiting Mecca
like
so Mecca is the home that Abraham peace
be upon Him built along with his son
Ishmael peace be upon him
and it gives the Muslims a unified
direction of prayer it's sort of at the
center geographically
uh of Who We Are
um and
when we pray towards it
it's not that
it's not that that's the only place that
you can supplicate turn towards but it
gives us a unified sense of direction it
gives us a unified sense of Prayer
so Mecca is
our Qibla it's our place of Direction
when we are alive and when we are dead
so actually we pray facing towards it
when we die we are also faced towards it
in our Graves
and it kind of gives us that unifying
spirit so this is uh the valley of Becca
also in the Bible spoken about the
valley of Becca
and um where other biblical Scholars
would also mention uh Mount Perrin
and it is the place that Adam uh in the
Quran Adam peace be upon him first had a
place constructed there as a place of
worship
from the Angels towards God and then
when Abraham settles Hagar and Ishmael
and Mecca
they build this house of worship
and that is where the gushing Springs of
zamzam are mentioned where God sends an
angel
to
give a miracle to Hagar and Ishmael that
they can sustain themselves from as
they're not left in the desert so
Ishmael being the firstborn son of
Abraham
is given a place and there's a story and
a history that's going to unfold from
that place of Mecca and then Isaac is
born peace be upon Him 13 years later
and there's a story and a history that
comes from that but ultimately
Mecca is the center Mecca is where we
turn towards for prayer Makkah is where
we perform the pilgrimage the Hajj
pilgrimage
once in our lives at least if we can
physically and financially if we find
ourselves capable we at least perform
the Hajj pilgrimage once in our
lifetimes but there are other
pilgrimages throughout the year you can
go
at any time of the day any time of the
year you will find people that will be
performing The Pilgrimage
an iteration of the pilgrimage in Mecca
and it's an incredible practice it
really is a place where
you feel like you're no longer in this
world I mean it's it's it's it's
incredible so we all go there donning
what's known as the ram Garb so the men
will wear uh just these white uh
garments which are
resembling or they they resemble the
garments that we will be buried in
and whether you're a king or a prince or
a peasant and you know in classical
terms whoever you are whatever
distinction you have you're all the same
and the women will wear a simple garment
as well so
you go there you relinquish all of the
pretensions and concerns and superficial
barriers and distinctions
that exist in this life and we do what's
called tawaf circle around the Kappa
symbolically putting God at the center
of our lives
we do seven rounds between Safa and
marijuana the two mountains where Hagar
when she once ran between those two
mountains with her baby Ishmael looking
for water trusting God was provided for
we too
go between the two mountains of Safa and
marwa to express that trust in God and
to follow in that way
and these are ultimately these are the
rituals that Abraham himself engaged in
um
in our tradition and the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him engaged in
and so we engage in the exact same
rituals and there are Divine wisdoms to
them that we may not even be able to
unpack and reflect upon
but it really is in that place where
um you find
the most beautiful Global expression of
Islam you see people from all over the
world people that don't speak the same
languages people from all sorts of
backgrounds and they're all doing the
exact same thing and in a matter of
seconds when the call of prayer comes
in a matter of seconds
two three million people get arranged in
perfect rows for prayer right and it
just it looks like this perfect Optical
you know uh vision of just Beauty when
you see people in unison standing bowing
prostrating
and you don't know who the person next
to you is
and that's where you know you you know
Malcolm X you read about the history of
Malcolm X when he went to Hajj that's
where his entire world view shifts
uh not just his previous
uh baggage but
the dream that he then had the
possibilities that he saw for people to
be able to overcome some of the false
distinctions that we have
uh race and class
and to see
God as one and to come together
and worship him alone and also seeing
each other equal participants in that
worship